[00:20:56] There is a ton of disinformation
and straight-up propaganda floating around
about Corona virus.
So I want to go over the actual science around
cures, treatments and vaccines that are being
investigated.
What's most promising timelines, et cetera,
before we jump in.
Remember, drinking silver won't cure corona
virus.
Prayer won't cure or prevent Corona virus.
Buying a two year supply of toilet paper certainly
won't help.
Black people aren't immune.
As was floating around.
This is not a Chinese bio weapon created in
partnership with Kim Jong un.
We'll get to that.
This is a virus.
And as such, we can look at vaccines, antivirals
and antibodies.
And then in the meantime, the treatment of
symptoms and of course, social isolation in
order to prevent transmission.
[00:21:49][52.8]
[00:21:50] The treatment of symptoms, of course,
includes things like breathing assistance
through ventilators and other things that
can be done while the body is attempting to
fight the virus off naturally.
Let's first talk about vaccines.
Vaccines take a while to develop.
There is a large range being cited for how
long it might take until a vaccine is ready
for public use.
You have to get through development, clinical
trials, approval, production, distribution.
There are some vaccines that are ready for
trials.
The timeline that is most realistic for a
vaccine being ready optimistically, we're
looking at eight months less optimistically
looking at 18 to 24 months sort of at the
most conservative.
There is already a vaccine from the Israeli
Miguel galili Institute because they've had
a poultry corona virus vaccine for a while.
They've modified it to be a human version.
It should be ready to test any day.
But again, the testing is the beginning of
a very long process.
There's a bunch of other vaccines in development
subject to the same timeline.
The vaccine is, of course, for people not
yet sick in order to make them immune.
No vaccine is 100 percent.
The idea is, if lots of people get it, you
can build herd immunity, reduce what's called
R0 or are not to below one meaning one person
is infecting no more than one other person
on average.
Right now the are not of covered 19 is between
1.4 and 3.9.
And obviously until we get that below one,
we will continue to have more cases.
Second, antivirals covered 19 is a virus,
not a bacteria.
So antibiotics would not work against it.
Antivirals are used to treat viral infections.
Antibiotics go in and destroy the bacteria.
Antivirals instead tend to prevent the virus
from developing, replicating or spreading.
There is a few promising ones being tested.
They all have their side effects.
One is called the room DVR.
It's made by Gilli AD Sciences.
It was developed for Ebola.
Didn't really work well for Ebola.
It's being tested in clinical trials right
now, including, I believe, in South Korea.
Now, there are conflicting reports about how
well it's working.
There was a report last week saying it's working
well.
Other reports saying it's not really clear.
It's working better than placebo and it has
significant side effects in a large portion
of patients.
We just need more data.
Maybe it's an antiviral that could be modified
to better work on Cauvin 19 with fewer side
effects.
There's another antiviral being tested in
Japan called AV again.
Now, this was actually developed by Fujifilm
and it was developed as a broad spectrum flu
antiviral that Japan stockpiled.
And it can have serious side effects up to
and including birth defects.
So women 18 to 40 straight up shouldn't even
be be using it at all.
Experts think this is probably AV again, not
going to work well enough to justify the risks.
And then we have the possibility of giving
people antibodies.
Antibodies actually neutralize the virus pathogen,
the specific one.
When you fight the virus off, naturally you
develop antibodies.
The idea is take the antibodies from patients
who have recovered and transfused them into
a serum which you can give to another patient.
The issue is that the logistics are tough
because right now the antibodies you can get
from one patient in the tests that have been
done are enough to give to one patient.
One to one is not a great ratio in terms of
the logistical task that's required.
It's being looked at.
There are also side effects, fever, allergic
reactions.
You can also transmit infections that's being
tested in China at the earliest.
It looks like fall then Dutch reach.
Researchers have found another antibody which
they say seems to be working against the virus
in lab settings and could be used.
To develop an antiviral, it's also early could
be a while until that is developed.
So as all of this comes together, what we're
quickly learning is the social distancing
work from home, avoid crowds, shut down restaurants
going out only for necessities like groceries
and medications, otherwise remaining isolated.
That's all we have right now.
And until some of these things can be developed,
we have to do that.
Unfortunately, too many Americans aren't taking
it seriously.
I don't want martial law.
I don't want police lockdowns that will get
very, very ugly.
So people have to start cooperating.
[00:26:32][281.7]
[00:26:33] Otherwise, it's going to get even
worse.
We'll be continuing to cover this on our Instagram
account.
Follow to David Tachyons show on Instagram
at David.
Back
to
you [00:26:43][10.2]
[344.8]